no ama la seconda volta ci sono riuscito
la prima sembrava un mongoloide per ora
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono vari generi ad oggi dopo che
domenica siamo tornati su beppe anche
ragazzi comincia con just do it che già
partenza va dice tutto no no però non
c'è shy affinché non vedo shia labeouf
che mi dici da due alla madonna che
carina seriamente zio ma come e vabbè lo
prendo tua madre putrida maledizione
sono quasi fermi fermi che ce la faccio
non vale così eve calmo stai calmo e
storia nostro livello non mi fa prova
del crisi sta roba
si no a perché sono morto prima
affanculo ragazzi è impossibile arrivare
alla fine senza che mi colpiscano ci
impegna veramente assurdo
a meno che non faccio tipo così porca
eva forse cazzo è successo quanto
impossibile si fa chiede ai baci e butch
è il tie break per un attimo non avevo
visto la lamina in basso a destra ancora
un metro e facevo uno dei file più
grandi della storia di è più il saio s3
di furlan che cazzo lo sapevo cosa ma
non ipad ci mancava solo questo guarda
pensate ragazzi a giocare alto livello
su sua piece con l'aifa che devi girare
l'ipad per per andare avanti c'è cioè
sarebbe tipo un ipad jackson una roba
del genere che figo poco jump dopo lo
sciopero un secolo che non ne faccio uno
di tipo contro cosa ho sbattuto ok
kiko cosa vuol dire perché etico che il
caso ha comprato dei trucchi grazie
frate però non sono un maschio io non mi
trucco anche se dovrei a breve le fa
vigendo dello scrivi frate qua goda equa
che ringrazio per il paragone con dio
amico mio prova mi sono un po esagerato
cioè non è che adesso dio arriva il mio
livello
ora sto livello fatemi capire che ancora
sta andando avanti basta dai zio
digerisci il polpettone di natale
dell'anno scorso e pasta c in mezzo
bravo fra cos'è sta roba odio sembra il
ballo dell'anguilla
ok ce l'ha fatta dopo un secolo e mezzo
easy c'è la prossima c'è un finale in
stone livello dove passa la mia vita
caminata dai frate gravissimo
componimento
ho dato una facciata ma ho vinto
l'importante questo gadget gaio e figo
perché giunti dai l'ho fatto anche
l'altra volta ho fatto una figura di
merda che era questo vediamo se adesso
hanno fatto una persona può niente merda
era e merda rimasto come faccio a non
saper volare con una roba così
con quale dolcezza poi 2016 world record
car jump la madonna amico mio prima cosa
innanzitutto questa non era la macchina
ma è una bici con insegna zio favier lo
so che è difficile capirlo per questa è
una bicicletta
ok la bicicletta non ha il motore non è
una macchina stai mentendo 46 ma ci
credete che ha vinto solo la faccia di
duke web monster truck addirittura fuori
che era bravo non lo fai vedere come si
può essere una macchina gesù dice forse
forse anche un po troppo maquinchao
ragazzi sono un po grosso per guidare
queste cose della madonna che botta ho
dato cioè abbiamo inventato la nuova
navicella spaziale che sarà in grado di
distruggere i meteoriti che è un monster
truck scusa è quelli stavano
festeggiando san valentino ma non hanno
capito che io ce l'ho più grosso grosso
al mont struck intendo è perché i
ragazzi non fa non festeggiate neanche
voi due non festeggiate san valentino
quando ci sono io ragazzi mai perfetto
dovete capire che o la madonna perché
tutta questa violenza sulle bottiglie
perché anche i tavoli perché ma madeira
cosa ti ha fatto sti poveri tavoli lav e
ragazzi l'importante che io abbia
vibrava non sai guidare io ancora no
però si impara che siccome ancora non ho
giocato nella mia vita a un livello con
gli arpioni serio facciamo farm un run
questo qui e che è il più giocato in
assoluto nella vita è invece una merda
bergomi rimasto luke ma come easy ok
normal ok e luke salvami to bravo
figliolo abbaianti va avanti
ansa stronzo la destructor bene tienilo
distratto punto sporca mignon sapevo che
non sarei stato in grado deficiente
professional
però la mia bici se la cava beh almeno
quello
[Musica]
addio quanto può essere difficile un
livello con gli articoli quanto ok ok no
perché sei stupido
dai che luke è ancora vivo oh che bel
papà posso prendere le tue gambe brutto
stronzo non osai sarebbe troppo figo si
mettessero le voci ok già fatta perché
ce lo fa so che tutti voi avete visto
transformer
ma questo questo è meglio ma ma tanto
meglio dai ragazzi non vi chiedo più
niente solo questo livello
porca [ __ ] che schifo e varate son
rimasto incastrato nel culo di mio padre
che bella cosa che non so come fare
abbiate il paziente cos'è
[Musica]
a me pensa di prende per il culo questo
ama me pensava di prendere per il cos'è
mini canto ho applicato il livello senza
leggere il titolo minigun torture e la
tortura con l'amica come fai a torturare
una persona con amica l'ammazzi eh
infatti che tortura e gwen esecuzione
ciao zio atto di sotto se ancora vivo
aspetta che ci provo frecce
[Applauso]
ogni tanto ragazzi non hanno la vita ho
vinto una gamba e ti posso venire questo
fantastico tris la epic facciamo un free
strauss serio serio però non come i
soliti ecco cosa ho appena finito di
dire ti verrà veramente non ci posso
credere
883 max pezzali conferma
ero stanco
the monsters izzo il mostro ti mangia il
livello è basato su al erge satan tizio
largo satana ti mangia un largo satana
talbet hulk a [ __ ] e vabbè è la madonna
che caso è mi si è andato qualcosa di
traverso zio non è rimasto bloccato
quando dovrà tossire per forza forza zio
tossisci ho capito che sei satana però
non potresti reggere un uomo e una
bistecca nell'esofago ero rimasti
incastrati simo anch'io quindi
rifacciamo che meglio stavolta non ha
centrato manco la bocca fantastico ci
siamo sono vivo
oddio c'è un dinosauro che cazzo e
addirittura un camion
vabbè azzi e ho capito che è stata una
tournée goethe poi magna i camion come
se niente fosse perfetto stato chiesto
chissà che ora ghazi fatte sei stato ne
andiamo avanti che meglio jana gul
matico di nove bello cos'è una roba
pixel
anche mosca se quali stanno buttando
giunti quale non sa che vanno a che figo
a io sono questo è bello ho appena
ucciso un tizio non so come posso andare
a uccidere in una chat no perché ecco lo
sapevo che dovevate farlo fuori ma il
bambino è dio che allora va bene che
sempre lo vuoi
certo che lo voglio vaga mi pagarti pec
o per luke ma the dawn manrovescio lele
viveva proprio non hai capito niente
acceso posso andare dal padre ciao papà
di uk dove mio figlio si chiama timi non
si chiama tim
spiegami per quale motivo dovrei dare
dei soldi a quel deficiente per un
familiare duke che lo odio a posso
passare quindi posso buttare giù questa
cosa ho detto ok che si possa andare a
prendere i soldi giusto grazie ho preso
io ho preso i soldi e così posso dargli
i soldi per prendermi uk che me frega a
me che poteva morire domani
ecco
giuro ora che non è un brutto finale va
bene non sono intristito anzi molto
meglio facciamo parigi il prossimo
by lovo kong l'ultimo che è in tipo di
impossibile
cosa devo fare
ma si può avere una mia allora se avessi
tentato di farlo non ci sarei riuscito
come cazzo è possibile se non posso mai
superare lascia papa che cazzo ma che ce
l'aveva quasi fatta lega ci aveva fatto
un salto incredibile 9 era bellissima
però è che devo caderci come sopra porca
eva c'ero quasi
[Musica]
sapete cosa
[ __ ] [ __ ] dal giorno ragazzi
il nostro riuscita volevo passare la
vita su questo livello però domani passa
a mia nonna trovarmi quindi no spero che
vi siate 100 ragazzi concludo con
l'episodio cosa se non sia piaciuto sono
un commento è un mi piace anche se di
facebook e come tale descrizione ci sono
riusciti scrittrici vediamo non possiamo
visto ragazzi
[Musica]